welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Jackson a professor of Spanish
and Portuguese his research interests
include Portuguese and Brazilian
literature's modernist Vanguard estándar
arts literature Portuguese culture in
Asia and ethnomusicology today we'll
talk with professor Jackson about a
conference he recently organized
entitled Goa a post-colonial society
between cultures
welcome professor Jackson thank you it's
a pleasure to be here
Goa so what gave you the inspiration to
organize the conference I did research
and Goa starting 35 years ago and have
kept at my interest over the years
within the category of the Portuguese
Empire the expertise territories in Asia
and I thought this would be an excellent
opportunity to bring together musicians
writers on Goa and to look into the
condition and theme of Goa over its long
existence as a part of the Portuguese
world and now part of the Indian Union
okay and Goa is in India it's a coastal
city in India girls on the west coast of
India about 10 to 15 degrees north of
the Equator on the Malabar Coast and a
strategic location for 450 years a bit
more it was part of the Portuguese world
and was the capital of the so called
Portuguese India that extended from
Mozambique on the Indian Ocean side all
the way to Japan on the other so it was
quite a cosmopolitan administrative
centre for hundreds of years okay and
give us an overview of the conference
the title of the conference a
post-colonial society on the one hand
pointed out or was directed toward the
idea that the Portuguese world the so
called lusophone world has not yet
really become part of the post-colonial
debate which was really initiated and
carry on more by Anglo Indian scholars
and I thought it would be a very
interesting idea to get the Portuguese
focus involved in the whole topic of
post-colonial tea but particularly since
the structure and nature of Portuguese
Indian society
was different from the anglo-indian the
second part that between cultures points
out the fact that ago ins have always
lived among various cultures with a
mixture of cultures and that this
condition which one finds throughout the
Portuguese world is an integral part of
globalization of today so I wanted to
point out how the example of core the
case of Goya predicted to a certain
extent and could help inform our views
and studies of globalization okay and
who were some of the people who came to
the conference so I was able to contact
several authors before I have a Yale
seminar I normally give called world
cities and narratives and for the book
on Goa I had used the novel titled
tbling by Victor anchovy beta and mr.
anchovy beta got in touch with me he
actually lives in the United States and
helped to organize the conference and so
through him I was able to invite dr.
Antonio Gomez a new novelist a
cardiologist at Mount Sinai Hospital ago
and has been in New York for 40 years
who's now written a very interesting
novel and also I was able to invite
Margaret muscadine yes a best-selling
author
the penguin edition of skin her novel
about go of visited by various
nationalities and people from different
parts of the world worked out so I was
able to have a roundtable with readings
and discussion with the three novelist
Victor Angela rebated Margaret
mysterious and Tony Gomez I'm interested
in the cardiologist what what is his
novel about so his novel called the
sting of peppercorns is said in 1961
when Portuguese rule in Goa ended and
India was incorporated into I'm ago I
was incorporated into India
so his novel really is about that moment
of invasion incorporation liberation and
so forth in December of 1961 okay let's
talk about some of the highlights of the
conference yes in 2006 I had organized a
conference called Portuguese world music
and there were some go and content in
that conference and professor Victor
Coelho from Boston University who's a
prominent
at that time played and he suggested a
concert for this concert of religious
music that was taken to Goa in the 17th
century and this would be Italian sacred
music so he played the Thera bow which
is a very long necked lute and
accompanied a male soprano which is
something that's one almost never hears
playing music of Carissimi and caps
Berger two composers of the 17th century
and this was in Whitechapel and with the
acoustics and the soaring voices it was
really splendid I think that was
certainly one of the highlights of the
conference ok and what did you have any
did you encounter any surprises
something that you didn't anticipate
during the conference well there was an
interesting sideline when one of the
speakers began talking about his going
topic then dr. Gomez stood up and said I
think we're cousins so many of the girls
discovered that they were related and
that was sort of the sub theme that all
Goines throughout the world have some
degree of kinship it's just a matter of
discovering what the context is with the
relative and that became a kind of
humorous under theme that that United
the members of the conference and gave
us all something more to talk about so
why do you think it's important to do
conferences like this well in this case
of course we have a Council of South
Asian Studies but within that account so
there's so many topics that could be
presented for conferences the idea of
doing one on a small territory is the
smallest state in India one that also
for hundreds of years
was ruled by a colonial power might not
be the first choice so I thought that
coming from my background having studied
a bit of ethnography Portuguese studies
literature and go that that would be an
angle that no one else in South Asian
Studies might have and this would be a
chance then to look at a different part
of India of one that's not so perhaps so
traditionally India but that mixes
Eastern Western themes over the years
yeah it is interesting because I
normally don't think of Portuguese when
I think of India I think of of course
England
so that is an interesting aspect so what
can we take away from the conference
what were some of the conclusions that
came out of it well I think we can take
away first of all that Goa is a dynamic
society undergoing tremendous change
so with this globalization we have the
NGO and diaspora that was one of the sub
teams that became prominent in the
conference and perhaps something that we
really learned that the Diaspora of the
gun population has been going on for at
least several hundred years particularly
in East Africa there were Goins who work
for the Portuguese civil service all
over the world and the Portuguese Empire
we had a even a presentation on Goins in
Brazil the places in the world that have
the greatest go in populations Toronto
and New York area other parts of the
world in Europe and so forth and
Australia of course many guns so the
whole idea of a global connection of
Goines society the returning to the
ancestor place the memories of what the
culture was like in the past these all
become prominent themes for people who
feel they're going identity but who
reside in various parts of the world
very good thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work thank you it's a pleasure for
more information about Professor Jackson
and his work please visit our website at
Yale ddu slash McMillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the McMillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty McMillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you